hi there back in vancouver
had a bit of a tiring day uh still have
that
flu
i think i'm getting slightly better
every day um on the plane a lot today
mostly on the plane i guess i was
two flights one from uh san diego to uh
seattle and then hang around there and
then seattle vancouver
so but mostly what i did was read that
japanese book with all the patterns in
it get my korean
patterns slammed in but
today is an exciting day
because i think i have found someone
uh it's amazing i'll get into more
detail tomorrow because i'm tired i'm
gonna go to bed but through odesk which
is an outsourcing site on the internet i
posted the request for someone to do
transcriptions to transcribe
kim jung-ha's podcast
and there are two people who responded
who i think uh
will do it within the range of what i
can afford to pay
uh the
one person has started
and she is a uh korean person who a
korean speaker native speaker who lives
in
the united states she teaches korean she
has a degree in literature she's very
interested in literature kim yong-ha's
podcasts are about world literature
she's very interested in the subject she
also transcribes audio for her students
so the whole project interests her she
has started
if i get them transcribed i will be a
very very happy man
uh i still have to see
uh kim yong-ha if we can then
put these into our library at link and
share them with other korean learners at
link
i have had communication with kim
yong-ha and i'm continuing to pursue
that
so hopefully
i'll have more to report as we have more
transcripts in and if i get permission
to share these in our library and link
so that's really exciting i mean i think
that's just just phenomenal really and
it's amazing the world we live in that
there's someone out there somewhere who
has uh shares interest with me who finds
this project interesting who wants to
participate
and uh who's going to be able to do it
at what i can afford
to pay for these 53
podcasts which are truly wonderful
podcasts
that's about it
short today short and sweet talk to you
again tomorrow bye for now